[MUSIC PLAYING]
GREGORY RAIZ:
Raizlabs is a company
that is focused on building
excellence in software,
technology, and design.
We do that through our work
on mobile applications,
and websites, and
technologies in general.
My name is Gregory Raiz, I'm
the CEO and founder of Raizlabs.
We really want to understand
the human problem.
And, oftentimes, the
hard problems in software
aren't just the technology
problems-- the API,
the how do you
connect these things--
but really getting
at the heart of what
people are trying to accomplish
and do in their day-to-day.
BEN JOHNSON: My
name is Ben Johnson.
I'm the Managing Director
at Raizlabs in Boston.
We decided to put our hat in the
ring for the Google Certified
Agency Program.
The first leg is
just having access
to a lot of what
Google is doing today,
so there is access to design
reviews, invitations to events.
And that's sort
of the base level.
And I think that's
hugely rewarding,
even in and of itself.
Having Google review your
app from a design perspective
is amazingly helpful.
So that's the first tier.
The second tier comes
with certified status.
There's a long application
process for that.
And once you have
it, it's something
that you can really say to your
clients that gives them comfort
that we're a reputable
firm, that we're
building great software in a
way that Google believes in.
GREGORY RAIZ: The certification
is a higher bar for us
to really
differentiate ourselves
from many of the other
companies out there.
It required us to really
dig into what that
means to be truly world class.
And we wanted to set that
bar for ourselves as well.
JON GREEN: My name is Jon Green.
I'm a VP Creative at Raizlabs.
The Google Developer
Agency Program
allowed us to have access
to engineers for the map
team, the design team
to figure out, oh, how,
can we actually do
some of these things?
And we could reach out
to them when we needed.
And also that allowed
us to set up and say,
we can make this success.
They might look
closer at this app
because we're a part of this
program, which has actually
been super helpful.
GREGORY RAIZ: Some
of the challenges
in building the Six
Flags app, and which
touched on some of
these are certainly
mapping technology and payment
technology, material design,
or the APIs.
Having access to the Google
team to really ascertain
how we're approaching
certain software
and ensuring that we're
building technologies
the right way makes for a
smooth development process.
BEN JOHNSON: We set off
to build the Six Flags app
with a pretty lofty ambition.
And it was to bring in-park
navigation and commerce
to the app.
The comfort of
knowing that Google
is there to help us understand
where they are heading
as an organization, and that
we're along for that ride,
is a really helpful
thing to know.
And as a business we know
that going forward we're
going to be at the cutting edge
of whatever Google is doing
through access to programs,
through collaboration
with their teams.
It's really helpful
for us to know
that six months, nine
months down the road,
we'll still be a
part of that process,
and we'll still be working with
them to figure out what's next.
[MUSIC PLAYING]